the emotional reason why Tyra Banks kept
her baby news so secret
the iconic supermodel revealed on
Wednesday that she and boyfriend Erik
asla are the proud parents of a new baby
boy via surrogate a source tells eg she
kept the news so private because quote
the heartbreak has been so intense with
many false starts and failed attempts
that she didn't want to say anything
until the baby actually arrived the 42
year old opened up about her fertility
issues on her show fab life in September
and I'm so tired of seeing on my social
media why don't you have kids why don't
you have kids you don't know you don't
know what I'm going through
you have no idea our source adds she
only informed a small circle of friends
just before announcing the news to the
world and that the journey to baby was a
long one quote
she's been trying for a year and a half
to get pregnant she has been harvesting
eggs for the last 18 months to make this
dream a reality and now that little York
has arrived our source says more babies
could be on the way our source says
quote she wants more